So last time we were talking about
how contraction mappings make it so
that value iteration converges you know,
in the limit that we end up
solving the Bellman equations.
I'm not going to want to say too
much more about value iteration,
but on one slide I want to at least
summarize a couple interesting things
that are worth knowing.
All right, so here's the first one.
If you think about QT star,
so that's the Q function
that we get if we run value
iteration for T star iterations.
>> Okay.
>> We know that it
converges in the limit.
We know that QT eventually
goes to Q star.
But here's kind of an interesting thing
that we know about the finite horizon.
So there is some T star,
less than infinity, that's polynomial in
the number of states, the number of
actions, the magnitude of the rewards in
the reward function, the number of bits
of precision that are used to specify
the transition probabilities,
and one over one minus gamma.
So that, if we run valuation for
that many steps,
the Q function that we get
out is Q sub T star of SA.
If we define a policy, pi SA,
which is just the greedy policy
with respect to that Q function.
That policy is optimal, okay?
So what we're saying here is
that we know that in the limit,
if we run value iteration for
an infinite number of steps, then the Q
function that we get out at that point,
the greedy policy with respect
to that Q function, is optimal.
But what this is saying is that
there is some time before infinity
where we get a Q function
that's close enough, so
that if you do the greedy policy with
respect to it, it really is optimal.
Like all the way 100% optimal.
>> So what that really
means it's polynomial and
the things you would expect to matter.
And so that's saying that you
can actually solve this in
a reasonable amount of time.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean any time I see the word
polynomial, I'm like okay,
what you're saying is,
this is reasonable.
>> Yeah,
now the trick in this particular think.
The reason it's not just polynomial
is this one over one minus gamma.
So as gamma gets close to one,
this blows up and that's not
polynomial bounded in say the number of
bits that it takes to write down gamma.
So it really is exponential in terms
of the number of bits it takes to write
down the whole problem.
>> Mm.
>> But even so, if you take
gamma to be some fixed constant.
Then one over one minus gamma might be
really big, but it's some fixed constant
and we're polynomial in all
the rest of this stuff.
So, what this really all boils down to
is the idea that once you fix an MDP and
the number of bits of precision
that your using to write it down,
then there's going to be
some optimal action and
the might be other actions that are tied
for optimal in any given state.
But the second best
action is going to be
some actual bounded
amount away from optimal.
So, it can't get arbitrarily
close to optimal.
It's going to be some distance away.
And what that gives us is that when
we run value iteration enough,
eventually the distance
between the best action and
the second best action
gets bigger than that gap.
And once it's bigger than that gap, then
the greedy policy's going to be optimal.
It's going to choose the actual
optimal action in all states.
>> So VI converges and it converges
in a reasonable amount of time.
>> It's not that it converges
The greedy policy with
respect to value iteration
converges in kind of
a reasonable amount of time.
>> Okay.
That's a much better way of saying it.
Okay.
I buy that.
>> This turns about to be
a consequence of Cramer's rule,
which we're not going to talk about.
But this is why, once we write down
everything with polynomial precision,
that we are guaranteed to get some
fixed size gap, between the best and
the second best.
>> It always amazes me how you manage
to get Seinfeld into our conversations.
>> [LAUGH] Kramer rules.
>> [LAUGH]